- Monday morning, headed
to Newark airport off to SF.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Sleeve" by Bobby Uzóma)
You can always
settle into the norm.
If you're under 30 right now,
you have so much time for the
rest of your life, you can
always get the safe job.
You can always go back.
You can never be back at this
place where you can take high
risks and do your thing.
(laughs) I just wanted to call
and say what's up and thank you
for watching my stuff
and wish you a great, great day.
I do think influencers arbitrage
and Facebook ads against those
audiences we can do better than
the high CPMs that they charge
for media that I don't think
is consumed as a high level.
And we've A/B tested that
at a extremely high level
over the last three years.
But again, there is a
reason to spend there.
That would be you
telling me politically you feel
like you need to do it.
That's DRock back there.
He's super sad 'cause I'm going
in to a three hour board meeting
right now with...
As I was saying, obviously you
can see with the choppy edit,
and leave that choppy edit
guys, I'm going into a boardroom
meeting for the next
three hours so I'm excited.
Obviously, you
can't see any of it.
But it's a beautiful day in
San Francisco so that's nice.
("Sleeve" by Bobby Uzóma)
I don't know if I have ever
really been in a classroom.
So this is like a first time.
This is a real classroom, DRock.
(indistinct conversations)
This is how I study,
this is how I studied.
Mhmmm.
Mmm.
Yes.
Tell him I said thank you.
- I will.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
- Keep it up, keep it up.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Bye.
- [Gary] If somebody
asked me what's the one rule.
The one rule, I was just sitting
here thinking what's the one
thing in the last 10 years
that really stands out to me.
I really genuinely believe the
reason I as a New Jersey wine
store owner over-indexed
was I every single post,
94 percent of my posts
I think about my audience.
Maybe more.
I just am stunned by people's
misunderstanding that this is
not a press release.
Like back to humble bragging
and things of that nature.
I don't know.
I wrote a book, one of my most
successful books was called
Jab, Jab, Jab Right Hook
and the thesis was
give, give, give and then ask
and I think everybody's in the
like give me, like
take, take, take, take, right?
Not even ask.
Everybody's just
basically using it as
a distribution to
whatever they selfishly want.
And so, I really believe the
best way to be selfish in life
which manifests in social today
is to be selfless in a crowd of
voices where
everybody's taking, you know,
I'm trying to give as
much as humanly possible.
- And what does that mean?
- I give away all
my best information.
All of it.
So in a world where a lot of
people monetize information,
I give it away
for free at scale.
I spend an ungodly amount of
time answering questions and
surprising people.
As my profile has grown and
people think it's cool to for me
to say hello,
I'll just do it more.
And so, I just think the
number, it's really very simple.
I think back to that statement
of we're being exposed.
It's funny to me.
I know what the current
conversation is of what social
is and what is it mean but it's
really funny that it's clear to
me the people that are
over-indexing are the ones that
are providing more value
than are asking for return.
I think one thing that's
really an unspoken thing that
manifested quite a
bit is self-awareness,
is putting yourself
in a position to succeed.
It was funny in
group one after the talk,
you know, we're talking there's
never been a thing in mankind
that you have to do.
So I don't there's one
right answer I do think reverse
engineering the founder
of anything is powerful.
And so, if you're not into it...
But, but it is
much more leverage.
You own you.
- Yeah.
- You don't own Gigi Hadid.
I think it's a very
special time for social.
It's grown up.
A lot of watching people aspired
to create a personal brand and
the truth is you have to,
your actions have
to map your ambitions.
So let me tell you
one thing about this.
That it can really
change your career.
Instead of thinking
about a million followers,
think about what you
actually want to happen.
So, I manifested
on being influential.
I don't have the most followers,
I just have the greatest impact.
So if you really know,
well not the greatest,
one of the big impacts, right?
So it might be 100,000 followers
but if the right
100,000 people are there,
you can have everything that
you ever wanted to happen.
Right, so if you want to be
a famous actor or actress,
of course that matters.
If you want to leverage your
personal brand as a business
development or to raise capital,
of course you
should be out there.
But as I went around the room,
there's a lot of people who
struck me as really
tried-and-true operators.
People that wanted to be great
at their craft and they felt
comfortable in their craft and
they're struggling with this
notion of do I have to do this?
I just genuinely don't
believe that and I think that's
something for
everybody who's watching that
they need to really consider.
It's so interesting, when you
were just talking I said to
myself, "My God, if
anybody here thinks it's a job,
"they shouldn't do it."
I mean it.
Like I really genuinely believe
that if it filters through your
mind that way, go focus
on what you want to do.
If you want to work all the time
on the formula of your product
then that's who you are.
You're not gonna win, you're
gonna waste a lot of time if
that sounds like a job.
So listen, I think you have
to reverse engineer
your patterns and I think
everybody can do their own thing
but way more important is if
I thought, I've built
two very large companies now.
For me to think that I would
have to really deeply become a
great CFO would
be a great mistake.
Why do you think I was pushing
so many of you to not do this?
I only care about time.
Which is why I have no interest
in any of you spending time on
something that you
have no shot of winning at.
Just 'cause
it's a thesis. Right?
And I think for you to
become a 24/7 media company,
if that sounds daunting, well
then maybe you just need to be
dangerous enough to
know what it's impact is
on your ambitions, right?
I just couldn't imagine the
thought of compiling or
I've got to post today.
You're not gonna win.
The audience is gonna feel it.
- [Tyra] Bye bye.
- [Gary] Thanks, class.
Bye guys, take care, good luck.
("Sleeve" by Bobby Uzóma)
The only way you
can get the output
to be exactly the way you
strategized it is if you control
the entire loop.
("Reflex" by SAINt JHN)
Come on 6-4-3.
Nice night.
Hit a homer.
How about a three-run homer?
8-4.
And ball four.
(laughs)
Take a picture, DRock.
- [Woman] Gary.
- Hey. How are you?
- [Hunter] Thanks for coming.
- My pleasure, man.
How you feelin'?
- [Hunter] Awesome.
- Yeah?
("Reflex" by SAINt JHN)
Yeah, wherever there's light.
What do you want, DRock?
Alright, Alexis, we're gonna let
you ask the question of the day.
- What gets you to subscribe?
- Oh, I like that.
You went with a real right hook.
- I did. (laughs)
- Strong day.
Class at Stanford, Tyra Banks,
board meeting for
one of my startups
and Giants-Dodgers game.
Hunter Pence,
#AskGaryVee at the end.
Should be a good one.
Dude.
- [Hunter] Thank you so much.
- Get better, feel better,
good to see you.
Thank you.
Awesome that was so fun.
- Thank you so much.
- So fun hanging with you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, headed out
first thing in the morning.
- Yeah, thank you
again for being here.
- [Gary] We are grinding.
Dude, such a pleasure.
("Reflex" by SAINt JHN)